[Music]
get on his butt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
twenty-six
it looked like he was going to pull over
1109 as the vehicle pulled over
15.
[Music]
[Music]
big
65
for me
[Music]
how you doing bud
you speak english
okay i'm super stunned right for the
highway patrol all right we got several
901 cars on there
you know why we might have gotten some
calls
you don't know you tell me
you're all over the road what's going on
with that
here actually i can't even hear you go
and have a seat up here for me
don't fall over
okay just have a seat
stand over there trooper
all right so uh
why are we kind of
all over the place and running off the
road
we got like what three four 911 cars on
you
what's up with that
okay where are you coming from
north carolina and where is your final
destination
because you're coming from north
carolina going to north carolina i got
you you happen to have your driver's
license on you
is it in the car
where
located
i can get it
where is it located
could it be in your bag maybe
do you usually put your wallet in your
bag maybe like a backpack
no
but i can get in there
just because we're not really listening
to what i'm telling you i don't want to
have any problems
all right
do you have any weapons or needles or
anything in your bag that'll hurt me
okay
stop
[Music]
he says
you pop my trunk please
[Music]
i don't want to unnecessarily go through
any compartments in your bag that i need
to be going into
medications
where is that
from
do you want me to go only into
the compartment where it's at or do you
want just want me to look for
okay
[Music]
give the license to the dispatcher
so you said you have a doctor's
appointment for your head coming up
do you mind if i ask what that
[Music]
zero zero zero zero zero
nine seven nine
okay
[Music]
[Music]
three double shots of barbell
okay and where did you have those
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just trying to piece together
because you said you're coming from
north carolina
um
i caught you okay today we have maybe a
little bit more than we should have
before we started driving yeah
i will handle it you didn't hurt me you
didn't hurt anyone else that's important
so we'll go from there all right hang
out with trooper rickerson over
here i'm showing that his 27 is
suspended
[Music]
he's 64 29.
[Music]
reach that back
[Music]
so
okay
would you be willing to consent to those
okay we're not going to do that here's a
little bit dangerous but i'm going to
have you go to rickerson you'll ride
with him and we'll go to another
location where we can actually hear each
other and all that stuff
but before you do that i'm going to
patch you down one more time if you'll
face my vehicle
what i'm going to do is i'm going to put
your phone and all your money that you
have put that back
your phone's right here
another phone yeah it's a little don't
go anywhere they'll stay there all right
talk to me okay
all right
um you're the one right behind me
and when we leave
because the money's gonna showing going
right into there pull right up behind me
with your camera on so we don't need to
do anything
money was placed in the glove box
open that door
[Music]
[Music]
him on the radio
that mr hardy consented to do for his
friday exercises we're going to relocate
him off the interstate and then
trooper richardson's going to be the one
handling it or driving him over there
wherever you want to go
[Music]
um
[Music]
mr hardy
all right we're gonna keep our hands out
of our pockets though okay i appreciate
you you jacksonville jack works man come
on yeah
well i just saw the shirt
all right i want you to stand on the
white line and face me you can hear me
pretty clearly
yeah okay good deal i just want to make
sure um do you wear glasses or contacts
you don't okay good deal all right so
what i want you to do is put your feet
together arms down to your side just
relax
you know what day it is
what i would like you to do i'm down by
your side feet together
and put them a little bit more together
like this look at my feet
okay look at my finger put them together
and i'm down to your side
we'll run with that
what i want you to do
is look at the very tip of my pen with
your eyes and your eyes only okay don't
move your head for any portion of this
exercise you understand so far
i'm trying to open your eyes
so what there you go
try and open your eyes as much as you
can i'd like to see your pupils okay
all right
your eyes open this way before
almost done
good close your eyes open them again
all right look at the very tip of the
fan follow your eyes your eyes only okay
son bugging you
all right we'll face me how about that
come down to yourself
okay good deal all right so we're going
to use this white line it's a pretty
flat level surface
nothing you got to jump over right
would we agree
do you agree with that statement or
do you agree that this is a pretty
straight line there's nothing
obstructing me from walking okay i just
want to make sure
all right
what i want you to do is to put your
left foot on the line in front of you
just like this okay
then i want you to put your right foot
with the heel of your right touching the
toe of your left just like this
then put your arms down to your side
wait for further instructions
okay don't start until i tell you to
begin
when i tell you to begin i want you to
take nine hills to toe steps down the
line they're gonna look like this
okay we're gonna look like this
one
two
three four
five all the way to nine so you're gonna
count each of those steps out loud on
that ninth and final step
and take a bunch of small steps and then
you're gonna return back down the line
nine more steps
you understand those instructions
would you like any part of them repeated
okay you may begin
good right
what's that okay well we still have a
couple more to do we'll see
all right go ahead and stand on the
white line put your feet together arms
down to your side i appreciate you being
so cooperative man i really do
all right so you're gonna stay with your
feet together and arms down to your side
all right stay just like that until i
give you more instructions all right
when i tell you to begin and only when i
tell you to begin i want you to raise
one leg doesn't matter which one
approximately six inches off the ground
you're gonna look at your elevated foot
and point your toe outwards
when you begin looking at that foot
you're going to start counting 1001 1002
1003 and so on until i give you the
verbal direction to stop
okay so it's going to look like this
one thousand years
[Music]
you understand those instructions
okay
you may begin
all right we'll move on to the next one
i want you to fall off
all right
together arms down to your side
all right stay just like that until i
give you
you got a bad knee okay
do you want to try it and step and raise
the other leg so you're not on your bad
knee
okay just making sure we're trying to
give you every benefit of down
all right
so when i tell you to begin i want you
to close both of your eyes and tilt your
head backwards just like this okay
then when i tell you to bring the hand i
direct upward touching the tip of that
hand excuse me tipping your finger
to the tip of your nose
after doing so immediately bring your
hand back down to your side
do you understand those instructions
okay we're going to begin
left
right
what
right
right
remember your eyes are supposed to be
closed so the sun won't even bug you yep
all right go ahead and relax all right
so get your arms down to your side close
your head tilt your head backwards just
like this when i tell you to begin and
only when i tell you to begin i want you
to start counting in your head not out
loud to 30. maybe get
a bit slower
hey give me another set of coffee
i think you missed 24.
no bigger guy we're gonna do two
handcuffs okay so the time is 9 54 am
you are under arrest for the offensive
dui okay
those two tires are those good on you
good okay
what i'm doing i'm just double locking
all these so they don't accidentally
cinch down on you okay
all right
18 13
18 13.
is
is taylor
is taylor 97 or canto
candle said he was gonna wait